as we remembered him as an incredible
film actor today we will be
commemorating five Disney stars who are
taking from us too soon in making this
video our aim is to pay homage to their
work and celebrate their lives we need
to use what we have and make the world a
better place for other people
Cameron Boyce known for his roles in the
show Jessie and descendants Cameron
Boyce was a beloved Disney star who is
said to have warmed the hearts of anyone
and everyone he encountered he was
brilliant and he's no longer with us
here at the age of 20 he already had a
blossoming career and was on his way to
making a name for himself off-camera
Cameron was involved in a number of
admirable initiatives including thirst
project an organization that helps bring
clean water to underdeveloped countries
being such a genuine role model the
world was heartbroken to hear of his
sudden passing due to a seizure many
took to social media to express their
sadness with descendants director Kenny
Ortega stating Cameron brought love
laughter and compassion with him every
day I was in his presence I will see you
again in all things loving and beautiful
my friend he was joined by many other
people Cameron worked with who also
spoke to his endless kindness and
compassion well does the tragedy that
he's no longer with us I think it's
gonna be really hard we believe Cameron
Boyce left the world a better place Lee
Thompson young in 1988 Lee Thompson
young landed the Raw's Jackson in Disney
Channel's the famous Jett Jackson the
show was about a teenage secret agent on
a fictional TV show called silver Stan
and Lee was its star vision Omega matrix
headquarters the show was so successful
that the creators decided to make a
full-length movie which ended up being a
hit viewers loved Jett Jackson's
character because he was an empowered
young man who teenagers could look up to
after the start with the mouse house Lee
went on to land roles in the hit TV show
Friday Night Lights in Smallville his
final role was playing Barry frost
partner of Jane Rizzoli on the TNT drama
Rizzoli and Isles when Lee didn't show
up on set one day the police was sent to
his apartment to investigate at the age
of 29 it was discovered that Lee had
taken his own life
friends and family responded by creating
the Lee Thompson young foundation whose
mission is to erase the stigma
associated with mental illness we hope
that in the future those struggling will
use his foundation as a resource when
seeking help Michael Gailey Toa Michael
Gael Ito was known for his role as Nick
Leiter in Disney's the jury
see I think I could help you out on
Saturday the show was based off the
Monday Night Football Club books by
gordon korman a series that followed for
teens who discovered the magic of a
jersey that can transport them into the
bodies of professional athletes michael
was taken from a suddenly at the age of
31 though cause of his passing was for a
while unclear Michael's brother Jimmy
has made a public statement confirming
that he had a heart disease at the
funeral friends and family decide to
make it a true celebration of life and
had fireworks floating lanterns and a
live band to honor him his brother
stated it was a day for us to remember
my brother and really celebrate the joy
he brought to everyone's lives at the
funeral nearly 400 people attended all
of which were friends it was said that
Michael had the unique capacity to bring
everyone together
mark Lynch well many people know that
the members of The Mickey Mouse Club
include Christina Aguilera Britney
Spears and Ryan Gosling you might not
know that Mark Lynch was also a
musketeer when he was cast he was quoted
saying he was excited to be a part of
something that would encourage young
people to pursue their dreams and a life
of purpose that guys here's to me
Michael Jordan that was really cool
while his co-stars quickly found success
after the Mickey Mouse Club
it took Marc some time to find his way
after working hard he finally appeared
on Broadway Simba in the Lion King which
was a total success he took a break from
acting and singing to take care of his
mother who was fighting pancreatic
cancer when she passed mark extended his
break from show business to process the
loss he later went on to compete on
American Idol giving memorable and
moving performances know I'm here to
sing because I don't wanna hear from
Simon it's not a dance competition such
as singing wind beneath my wings which
stunned audiences at age 34 he
tragically passed away from acute and
chronic alcoholism he will be remembered
for his angelic voice and kind and
giving spirit Matthew Garber the Matthew
Garber passed away in the 70s we wanted
to include this Mary Poppins star you'll
remember him is playing the young
Michael Banks who's transported into a
magical world by strict but mystical
nanny
he won our hearts when he reacted to
Mary Poppins sliding up the banister and
setting him straight
who's your mouthpiece Michael we are not
a codfish while visiting India Matthew
sadly contracted Hepatitis and was
unable to recover he passed away at the
age of 21 and will be forever missed
because each of these actors dedicated
their lives to their craft with such
passion and dedication we can only
describe them as awe-inspiring
they passed too soon we will always
remember them for their work and will
continue to celebrate them for years to
come which stars impacted you and why is
there any that we left out that you
would like to see commemorated let us
know in the comments below until next
time